the Joe Rogan experience people don't
know you have that gear or you forget
look you do voices really well I don't
have that many though I can only do a
few I think are you the type though
where if you're doing a bit and you need
this person to talk or whatever you'll
you'll figure it out yeah I can get a
few there's a few voices I can get out
you know yeah cuz you're hella cones and
like you know I like so well I've known
Alex for like more than 20 years so it's
that's just easy yeah I've hung out with
that guy we've been hammered together so
many times it's like it's that is the
most misunderstood guy on the plants
need somebody next to him that's what he
needs someone to go Alice let's slow
down like you had a really good point
there but you see the manager he even
agree with me we talked about I said you
just need like a rational journalist
who's next to you to like study goes
you're right you're right you're right I
do need that and I go just you need
someone who's just analysis it out look
he was right about all this Jeffrey
Epstein [ __ ] that is a [ __ ] fact Alex
Jones called this years ago years ago he
was saying that they take a lot of
famous people to this island and they
have all these young girls that this guy
hooks them up with he was talking about
this years ago now it is mainstream news
and this human hybrid experiments yes
yes sounds like a complete joke brought
it up we were like we were like what now
it's [ __ ] mainstream news this is a
fact man like people want to write that
guy off because he'll tell you he's
crazy he'll let you know he's crazy I
mean on my show there was one of them of
the favorite funny things he ever said
he's like look I want to be honest with
you I'm kind of [ __ ] I fell to the
ground laughs but that's who he really
is man people just have him lumped in
you know it's like some people they
don't represent the best aspects of
themselves right to people and then
other people try to define them like
people try to define you it's really one
of the things that it's really kind of
weird about the more famous you get the
more people try to define you in a way
that's detrimental or a way that's
dismissive and limited like I've noticed
that after this Bernie Sanders thing
that I did so anybody listening to this
you if you're saying this I am NOT right
at all so stop saying that it's silly
it's foolish I've interviewed right-wing
people I am 100% left-wing the only
thing that stops me from the only things
that I disagree with about left-wing
people is support for the military
support for police in the Second
Amendment it's probably it everything
else
across the board I lean way left in
terms of like Bernie Sanders made a ton
of sense to me and I would 100% vote for
him Tulsi Gabbard is my favorite I mean
I'm not I'm not a right wing person so
this nonsense like so many people were
saying that you know the Bernie Sanders
spent this time on a right wing podcast
like what what do you say sure and don't
you think he weighed the pros and cons
of like it was an opportunity for him
and I think I think was a win any idea
who I was
really yeah I think it was one of his
young staff members who's friends with
Kyle kolinsky who is a really good
left-wing progressive talk show guy on
YouTube and Kyle hooked it all up and
this this idea that you know it's bad
for someone to talk to people it's just
it's foolish yeah this is a weird thing
that's going on right now I thought was
a great platform for him and I get his
ideas out there and to be heard in
something other than just sound bites
yes I could be taken out of context it's
a great platform I think for anyone
who's running for anything to have a
long-form conversation and it's good for
us too because we get to find out who
they really are
you really can't hide in a long
conversation yeah three hours
yeah you can't I would do an hour and 10
with burn that's all he has
you know the guys running for he's legit
running for brekkie could be president
right he's not like you know some people
that are running for president like all
right bro was that guy Zoltan what is
his name he was the guy was running the
transhumanist platform ish Devon how do
you say his last name very nice guys
that is for this coming out was the last
one
it was 2016 we had him on but you know
it was like one of those guys all right
like Ben Gleib you like good luck
[Applause]